une production du studio sf
bio venus sans filtre et des podcasts on
parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos invités
date site je paie rh quentin avec moi
d'une plainte
par mario
bava le studio est ta est à louer pour
vos projets de podcasts pour vos projets
de n'importe quoi de conférences de
cours en ligne de discussion de limites
vous venez ici on s'occupe de tout
nicole et le la technique les micros ça
sonne bien ça nous good read less with
bein si tu essaies filtre au studio tout
ce qu'ils avaient besoin et de la
schlague dans le frigo une expérience
client exceptionnelle
vous serez pas déçus et en plus ces
prochains aujourd'hui ph qui sera en
kiosques aujourd'hui on a reçu la
personne derrière la page instagram elle
investit qui est une part d'instagram de
vulgarisation sur les finances
personnelles on a discuté vous l'aurez
deviné dans l'introduction j'aime par
deux finances personnelles si comme moi
vous êtes parmi les illettrés la finance
le machu
misérable honnêtement je vais le diriger
j'ai pas peur de le dire d'hommes il
connaît le sort lui déjà plus on a
failli y adhérer rdc l'utilisent à faire
leurs adieux mais si vous êtes comme moi
vous ne connaissez absolument rien à
science ce podcast le est absolument la
finance pardon ce podcast est absolument
pour vous même si vous êtes déjà avancé
dans le milieu et beaucoup de concepts
qui vont vous être utile on a parlé de
quoi faire avec son argent comment
investir qu'est ce qu'un fond on a parlé
du mobilier aussi on a parlé de la
différence entre un colocataire piètre
acheteurs être propriétaire
puis on a parlé de
quelque chose qui moi m'a permis de
vraiment mieux dormir pis ces deux
d'enlever la pression de devoir gérer un
budget me déplace ton argent la fin de
la semaine connaître ceux qui suivent la
poursuite des actions pi 6 po essentiel
c'est pas ça pas besoin d'être compliqué
mais vous allez comprendre pourquoi la
matière pis si pour vous c'est un sujet
qui est stressant qui disent ils
approchent
comme on dit nous nous mêmes tph t'aime
moi non plus j'ai pas un expert là
dedans mais je pense que ce cas cela
peut aider un petit peu saisir des bases
savoir par où commencer
puis un petit peu déstresser avec plus
puissante et juste est capable de
prendre après ce diptyque d'action pour
faire que vous allez poids épargner
investir un peu prendre des bonnes
décisions au niveau financier a quiet
fait craquer une chute
un ring relaxe écoutez ce puits
remercie ne m'a tellement donné que le
pote cadre cette semaine et présenté par
mindscape si vous écoutez en ce moment
en vidéo je me suis rasé une moustache
parce que je voulais essayer de voir de
quoi sa valeur dans top gun le soir un
obstacle la moustache comme tel est
vraiment moyenne ça va aussi vous êtes
en charge sur votre cerveau pas la peine
d'aller voir sur youtube non mais elle
est un petit repos ce mec est vraiment
juste la moustache ça flashe se trouver
décalé jeunesse bref je les fait avec le
langoureux 4.0 de minsk et puis j'ai
fini c'est ici avec le syli appel sur le
crochet vers mes restaurants on va se le
dire le sport pour tous pour les
couilles mais aussi pour la face pis
lyon le platane en paquets d'hommes qui
ont sorti keelor l'horizon leur package
est un absolu
quand j'ai vu puisqu'il me lasse pas
quelque chose politique j'ai failli
tomber dans marché gens croyaient pas au
mieux
puis je vous sors c'est la liste obtient
un rappel par k o fillol et l'envoie 4.0
que j'ai parlé il ya le coup à plusieurs
heures qui gère une petite ville d'oran
pour les couilles le crom revival qui
est un tourneur pour les boys débarque
sur les banques sortent d'un grand fan
de ballon et je me suis mis bones a
préféré son avantage et même dormir
c'est excellent il ya un travail bâclé
montrabe au bacchus et les yeux tout le
lalalalala grandes compagnies d europe
se laver dans douche donc shampoing
restait l'un deux en or body wash avec
l'odeur caractéristique de magnifiques
bien même la crème l'esprit hydratant
l'esprit de ratage on n'est plus
tellement je l'utiliserai me le mettre
dans mes potes que je méritais année là
c'est que je suis déçu par ma peau au
soleil le suite à thé je suis bronzé
jeune âge d'or life is good hair basket
entre crêpes promo pour vous autres le
sans filtre pour 20% de rabais et la
livraison gratuite sur deux là dessus
comme quoi
on a juste une vis à vis puis c'est avec
masques
merci mme skalli merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrête s'est passé
merci les bleus ouais on voulait
aujourd'hui
la semaine passée comme comme je t'avais
dit promettant leur sujet martin ça on a
parlé d'économie pour parler d'économie
globale plus de global le contexte
économique dans quelques on se trouve
puis on avait envie de parler un peu
plus de finances personnelles des trucs
pas gérer son argent sur quelqu'un qui
connaît pas sa part tout qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que c'est pour ça qu'on
a pensé à tout pis le
ski est incroyable
on a reçu des fois des livres mettons
nos invités mais c'était pas un sous
forme de cadeau laissé le terme
j'aimerais
nantis car l'être avec
fait qu'un résident à maurice renault
pointe des ports pour la conversation
parce que j'ai comme l'impression comme
on disait en blague que ce sera pas les
potters
fax et le livre la retraite à 40 ans de
jean sébastien pilote comment déjouer le
système pour atteindre la liberté
financière déjouer les systèmes malades
auteur du blog je leur ai dit ce que
vous le connaissez moi je connais pas
moi je n'ai pas non plus non plus à quai
mais je pense que vous avez trouvé
interressant puis je me suis dit vous
allez pouvoir vous échangez
ouvrir les bras qui on n'a pas la même
chose non ce sont des choses n'est pas
la même forme et je veux qu'on parle un
peu de ce puits ça sera notre notre
point de porc parce que on entend
souvent la retraite de liberté 45 la
retraite à 40 ans le pis moi le jeu
vieilli dans le temps je range est à 31
ans arrivé depuis je me rends paul
s'en prendrait un billet de loto gagnant
mais ton métier sauf que ce concept là
de liberté 40 et 2 45 verte et 50 est ce
que c'est un concept que l'on peut
appliquer peu importe la seconde
année pas de quel âge mais d'enfants lui
juste pour la petite histoire il ya
commencé par nier que lorsqu'on a
compris sa conjointe pire il ya
énormément épargne investie pendant 15
ans il ya vraiment vécu bovine je pense
qu'ils aient j'épargne et 50% de mon
revenu n'est apte à
50 % à 50 % de son est bon que puis
après qu'un incendie a pu prendre sa
retraite
juste avant 40 ans paraître sa conjointe
aussi a pris sa retraite mais lui c'est
vraiment des investissements à la bourse
noté lui tout ce que le seul bien
immobilier qu'il l'a donc on sait son
condo qui a payé cash avec l'argent qui
a fait en bourse payer son coin de cash
qui le pensent a fait quelques années
qu'ils qui est à la retraite elle y vit
très modestement et une part qu on y
voyage aussi ce qui est vraiment
important pour lui voyage
sont payés sont évidemment pas axé sur
les biens matériels allait quitter avant
de de parler d'eux c'est quoi les moyens
mettons pour arriver en retard à 40,1
question mettant plus les effets de ce
qu'on veut
quelque chose c'est mettons
tous quelque chose que tu poses quelque
chose que tu t'étais c'est d'atteindre
moi c'est tous la liberté que la
retraite et j'adore mon travail j'adore
ce que je fais je ne me verrais pas mais
en fait c'est ce qui dit aussi très
occupé il ya d'autres projets que son
effacement que
c'est vraiment gratifiant même si si si
tu te poses pas payant par rapport à au
travail qui fait avancer ce que j'ai
compris mais c'est pas gratuit à une
communauté qui sent qu'il est en train
d'aider acti city je suis pas occupé
même si je fais pas de job racing mais
je contribue quand même de manière à la
société
parce que moi l'idée mettons de
ça prend quand même quelque chose qui va
te motiver à travailler le matin la
place de jaude 2 un oisif puis de dire
enfin j'étais arrivé que travailler pour
sa retraite il ya quelque chose là
dedans moi qui m'a toujours dérangé de
dire aujourd'hui travaille pour ma
retraite ça semble contre intuitif à
dire que tu te lèves le matin pour une
espèce de ligne d'arrivée ti il ya
quelque chose là dedans mon modèle je
vais être bien a bel et bien quand ça va
être fini c'est ma soeur ma vie j'ai dû
amener parce que ma soeur avait toujours
travaillé vraiment vraiment fort à
l'école qui était avec des difficultés
à l'école l'enfant puis elle a toujours
la difficulté à travers tout un peu fort
que les autres la même chose dans le
marché du travail avait vraiment tout le
temps plus fort que les autres pour un
résultat semblable amené à m'avait dit
j'ai tellement hâte d'être en retrait
depuis été géré à l'université
st john mais en même temps sa qualité
son réflexe de dire j'arrête je t'aime
ce soit fini avant
d'être fini c'est vrai que quand même
cette question
mais c'est pour ça que personnellement
c'est pas pour moi un très petit et je
prends je ne sais pas si vous avez
regardé un peu de publications mesbah à
l'extrême la tige je pense que c'est ça
qui qui rejoint les gens parce que c'est
oui je fais quand même des bons choix au
niveau venant de ce côté là mais si je
me permets qu'un moyen de tiges de pense
quand même que j'épargne pas 50% de mon
revenu nerfs des je fais des choses
sensées mais pas à l'extrême et qu'avec
moi c'est pas comme ça que je veux vivre
ma vie quand est ce qu'on sait qu'on a
su épargner pour notre très belle ya
plein de règles de calcul place va c'est
comme à la fac taille attend juste me
soulem pendant la mauvaise chose
savaient pas vraiment de des dépenses en
fait donc
de ton revenu parce que comme par
exemple lui et sa conjointe il dépense
quelque chose comme 30 ou 35 mais par
année à deux facteurs
au grand je ne pense pas
à ce moment-là s'approche il m'a jamais
dit son chief le may était pas me sens
bien qu'on dit le début des publications
qui dit
comment épargner par mauvais temps pour
être millionnaire à 65 ans est ce que ce
que à partir de la rue à laquelle du
comment mais est-ce que c'était genre de
chiffres c'est un genre de
standards pour dire qu'ils y mettons à
ça je le sais je pars en retraite
c'est un genre de montant qui qui qui
fonctionne ou ça n'est pas vraiment
ouais mais en fait c'était plus
illustratif parce que les gens et on
vraiment aucune des deux
combien m puis c'est quoi le normalement
le taux de rendement factice est
illustrative ça dépend aussi des
objectifs de chacun je
veux demander si comme si à 65,1 mettons
600 millions dans mon compte en banque
si tu comme un genre dans le bal parc de
ce que ça me prend pour dire qu'ils
jugent pour alan branch caf un
comportement oui mais normalement tu
savais pas ce que je vais en parler dans
des populations qui s'en viennent mais
si ça va être quoi des revenus à la
retraite une pension à ce qu'ils étaient
par exemple moi je crois au gouvernement
j'ai une pension garantie à vie quand je
vais avoir un jeu montrant vos 35 ans de
service
faki aussi 7% leur qui on doit
considérer
harpiste épargne personnelle illyriens
mais normalement la règle une règle
s'appelle la radicale pour sarah c'est
ce que tu peux retirer par exemple je
sais pas moi 500000 danton rien je peux
retirer 4 % par année sans jamais que ça
ça manque et il m'a manqué parce qu'ils
ont fait plus de rendement encore plus
d'intérêt supérieur de rendement que ce
que tu partirais donc tout autant qu'un
genre genre mais ça dépend du montant
que tu as besoin de retirer
moi je comprends c'est là je me suis pas
exactement de la règle même sens que si
demain tu entends ton montre que ça
prenez n'importe quoi la c25 belle fête
x 20 fax ce montant la côte a besoin
pour ta retraite puis le à ce moment là
tu fais sites touristiques peu plus que
4 % par année ou jamais manquer d'argent
comprend dix mois mon grand père a mené
avait dit si planification financière
pour arriver jusqu'à la fin de sa vie le
pis a m'a déplu en santé qui pensaient
qu'à l'ére être fait qu'il ya eu une
réunion familiale pitié je vous à la mi
mai mais ma soeur mais ma cousine mes
cousines maintenant ont eu des enfants
puis l'heure mon grand père il fait une
réunion familiale pour dire le je vais
arrêter donner l'argent noël parce que
je pense qu
il ya quand même des dépenses qu'il
n'avait pas planifié dans mon plan parce
que les yeux des petits enfants puis
faut que dans des cadeaux de l'argent 10
10 le joug arrêter maintenant parce
qu'ils avaient osé shoot un petit brut
sous son niveau de santé les tacles à la
dure et puis aussi le nombre
mais l'image est belle image suite à
deux chiffres dès sa publication lui
quand même fort dans laquelle point ça
fait différent sur le long terme de
commencer tout juste eu des chiffres
mais je me suis informé et commence à 20
ans ce texte chose comme 236 et c'est
déjà dur 237 2 mo par mois
pour 20 65 1 millions e à 30 ans c'était
comme c'était comme cinquième place pour
être sûrs que les gens comprennent ne
fait pas 235 dollars par mois d'épargné
frais de 9 sec dans son compte de banque
et investi à je pense que j'avais mis 7
points 5 % par année puis moi c'est ça
dans l'investissement puis
c'est un des sujets sur lequel je me
suis moins penchée de l'existence non
plus passer sur l'anatomie des fourmis
ne me suis plus penché sa biologie mais
tant pis tu es quand j'ai du temps à m
je le mets pas danseur parce que moi
j'ai jamais eu dans mon compte en banque
de l'argent en surplus t depuis que juge
chez mes parents jamais eu l'os
financiers ou est ce que je me suis posé
la question qu'est ce que je fais avec
ce que j'ai jamais réfléchi à sauter
puis
quand qu'on parle d'investir pas juste
avoir de l'argent dans son compte
chèques parce que moi c'est mettre 200
pièces dont un compte chèque de côté je
dois je comprendre quand il relève que
ça fait rien mais quand on dit faut
aimer ton qui à 20 ans tu commences à 29
ans investissent 237 $ par mois un
rendement de 7 points 5 % qu'est ce que
ça représente un rendement de 7 points
5% séoul tulle investi pour être sûr
d'avoir rendement de 7.5 pour 5 pas de
faire baiser par par la bourse qui
crachent super wherever genre parce que
si ça se peut aussi c'est de mettre
parce que la semaine passée que jean
marais à 5 me disais dans les dernières
années c'est les gens qui ont eu l'appui
le maire investissements c'était du cash
le triste d'avoir d'argenton compte
chèque à cause du crash des démarches et
fait que c'est quoi maintenant quelqu'un
que vingt ans que les coutures qu'il ya
trente ans qu'il me mette qui se rend
compte que 530 yade à mettre de côté ou
à investir c'est quoi qui fait parce que
je connais rien j'ai aucune démarche
serait même pas je me donnerais qu'il
conviendrait qu un chèque me donnait 550
pièces par mois j'aurais po lu m georges
serait pas quoi faire et on perd on peut
commencer à la bande
2,6 a sûrement déjà vu reér
intérêts élevés ces liens à intérêt
élevé si le real ça fait un moment que
ça existe mais le cic juste depuis 2009
puis comment ils brandissaient à ce
moment là c'est au banc des siens
comptes épingle ses incompétences
spécial ou est-ce que tu peut générer
des intérêts non l'imposant maintenance
en tant que les intérêts perçus lycée
comme quoi 0.25 pour cent pour cent ses
chansons
factice aussi d'enfants on devrait pas
plus un celi un compte et peint on
devrait l'appeler en compte
d'investissement est ce que tu peux
investir à travers ton cv d'enfants au
juste pour revenir à l'essentiel puis ce
feeling c'est ainsi que récemment je
pense des dents les aveugles il eu 38 %
des québécois sont prêts ils savent
c'est quoi vraiment réellement un des 38
pour cela qu'ils aient passé l'épaule
stèle a quand même touché de l'argent
investi dans derrière des c'est même là
tu me parles à -3 puis les 38% des zooms
store qui sont elles-mêmes gagne son âme
a gagné à moi mais je t'avoue qu'avant
je pense 26 27 ans l'agent les 32
j'avais pas vraiment non plus bouger
jusqu'à 30 hors
vacances
[Rires]
et les carrés à d'enfants
analogique mcsween avait fait puis j'ai
beaucoup aimé d'enfoncer des tops ware
qui est que tu peux déposer ou est ce
que alain tandis qu'elle tu peux déposer
les investissements factiva avoir des
actions des obligations des fonds
négociés en bourse tout en comprenant
honneur c'est quoi exactement enfin
d'enfants tous les gains que tu génères
à l'intérieur de ses taux par un spécial
labatut paie pas d'impôts faire
d'enfants par exemple moi je sais pas je
dis n'importe quoi j'achète une action
de hochelaga même temps que son accent
cotées en bourse j'achète un piège là
par hasard fait que j'ai doublé mon
argent
ce gain leur vadis parce que la
compagnie a pris les actions attend
exactement avant que je l'achète à st
gall accents blues alors je décide de
vendre jusqu'à ma je vais matériel ils
achètent à prévert dont celui oui
d'enfants ton ces lits d'enfant il ya
deux façons d'investir essentiellement
c'est soit tu le fais par toi même à
travers comptes de courtage en ligne
donc dans le fond vos seins sont
financés h vous êtes avec qui des
jardins dans la salle personnellement
chaque banque nationale fait que j'ai un
compte de courtage chez par le sonar ce
n'est pas un peu mais daglan fond
d'appels où es-tu en ligne tout comme un
compte de courtage se trouve à concilier
à l'intérieur concours de courtage et un
réel je peux le faire partout où il peut
tout faire au téléphone je suis
excessivement compliqué non je peux
choisir parce que moi je moi c'est pour
moi j'ai pris moi j'ai choisi enfants
c'est projet pas choisir qui il veut
investir dans tesla après laquelle
plateforme moi je suis avec desjardins
fait moins dans le fond
je suis allé
chez moi dans le fond depuis que j'ai
commencé à être travailleur autonome je
savais que tu es personnes qui mettait
de l'argent de côté une partie côté que
ce métier pour moi c'est fait le pim et
profond s'agite m'alimente audi 80
contre train prend une partie de ce
groupe i mais un parti
la clé c'est sans que ce soit aussi
systématique et ce à chaque fin d'année
s'il me restait de courant dans mon
compte chèque je faisais bon ben je vais
prendre une partie du jeu me garder un
petit beau frère mais je prends ce qu'il
me reste puis je veux le mettre ta
clique pas les meilleurs mais céline et
moi je suis juste allé chez desjardins
puis voir l'a dit madame
concernant financier rappelait un peu
mon profil têtu risque était dispo
risque est têtue long terme du court
terme cela dit bête si côté valoir mes
tantes et ufo l'environnementaliste tous
genres pas pendant tout ce temps
investir dans une campagne petrol oui
mais non c'est là que le mou j'ai choisi
comme un genre de fond qui comme
finalement
plein de compagnies sur l'espèce de
collectif de compagnies dans quelques
temps investi un peu dans toutes ces
affaires lui mais c'est pas toi qui fais
sourcils bt est là avec ce en posant des
questions à déterminer son profil quel
enfer toi tu étais tout risque était
dingue risques immédiats qui ont votre
médecin le meilleur rendement mais que
des risques de crash et 5ème du nom
secret si quelqu'un qui voit que ça
accroche qui a battu tous ses sites où
ça faisait mal aux intolérances obtenu
avec le fait que après ce tout se fait
tout seul c'est moussa saïb a été
compliqué en fait c'est pas la madame
qui
choisissent eux mêmes leurs enfants oui
j'imagine un portfolio de fonds maison
desjardins c est la dia qui donne toi
tes risques et mettre dans ce fonds je
pensais que stafford le monde dirige les
fonds j'imagine que c'est des gens qui
connaissent le haka tpiy qui s'occupe de
jeu
parfait c'est pas tout le temps ils
réussissent pas toujours à battre le
marché cinq ans qu'il si on veut rentrer
là dedans c'est que le marché je sais
pas si jean marc parent pour mes enfants
commente évalue le marché boursier ce
qui est des indices boursiers
un enfant pour prendre la température
extérieure du printemps noir pour
prendre température du marché boursier
bateaux des indices boursiers puis celui
qu'on entend souvent parler puissant le
voir dans le livre que juste le faire si
les indices s p 500 chaque système pour
stand up and power stone est en partie
une agence de cotation américaine puis
s p 500 pour les 500 plus grandes
compagnies américaines enfants fac
social indices boursiers à ça ça se
compte en point mais présentement je
pense qui est un jeu pas n'importe quoi
2 ou 3000 points un moment déjà été
quatre mille facettes souvent que ça le
crash voit que le marché a baissé
ça pour ça que c'est pas tout les
revenants du début le s p 500 depuis les
années 20 et produire un rendement
annuel d'environ 10% par harry parce que
je voulais devrait pas ses pâtes ou les
conserves à tous les fonds qui bat lundi
10 mai tous les fonds qui vont générer
un rendement de 10% par mois mais est-ce
que c'est tout les fonds qui génère un
romain où il ya des fonctions dans le
méga tube oh et à déformer sa des
parties par exemple si le marché fait je
sais pas - kenza qui est fait laisse en
paix une somme qui fait moins 18 ou
moins bien depuis des années
citons fond il est à moins 10 j'étais
quand même content parce que dit il ya
quand même mieux fait c'est toujours au
marché ouais c'est ça ton très chaude
enfants fait que c'est comme un jour
d'indicateurs de
6e s'accroche à dire que ça accroche un
peu partout
cécile snp présentement il était à +25
quatre enfants il fait moins trois
belles le moment je comprends puis le
mettons je retourne à la personne ne
vint en 230 pièces à mieux pour investir
dans un celi ce serait une bonne
solution
mais l'enfant leur faut faire attention
aux steelers à 20 ans oui on assume que
tu te fais pas beaucoup un gars revenus
saint louis à ces lycéens bons véhicules
saab on tape haut rhin mais la personne
peut pas juste déposer le blackberry
pearl mais sauf que ce qui est conseillé
tu veux faire fructifier son agence et
de choisir des produits placement à
l'inter de ton série
parce qu'il ya des gens qui pensent que
le styliste le placement entier des gens
qui disent avait gelé déjà entendu à
montréal fait plus d'argent qu'elle
s'est lui je fais que j'aime pas mon
celi parce que montréal à présent jamais
la même chose à l'inter de ton cynique
et son créateur le même rendement moi
j'ai compris se veut pas longtemps moi
je pensais que juste comme
géraldine pas longtemps que ça s'est mis
à cracher que mon celi et punir ailleurs
été des actions moi je pensais que
c'était juste il y avait des accents et
à
moi c'est ça piqué ça pouvait mouche
parce que je sais que je mettais mon
agenda puis il monte plus vite que dans
mon prochain
combat ouais mais jamais satiriste
actuellement vriendt way we meet et ce
jusqu'aux jeux jamais juste critiquer
comme c'étaient des actions mais quand
l'amarante tête expliqué jeremy font
étape à 10 ans est un fonds d'actions ce
soit le cas maladie
[Rires]
parce que ça fonds d'actions ou sa faune
quoi c'est quoi les options en fait je
sais pas je connais pas les produits
déjà palmé d'or défendra accent à 10
dans les accès des compagnies
américaines accompagnera pnd font un peu
de tout le même sens et investissant
quelque chose c'est si tu nécessairement
des actions
risquées normalement je ne sais pas je
connais pas le produit des jardins mais
normalement ça va être 80% action 20%
revenu fixe des obligations donc ceci
est la portion plus safe de son
portefeuille d obligations ce qui
est finalement c'était les cartes sim et
d'avocats mais c'est justement
plombe dès qu'on peut parler qu'on peut
aller vers ton parcours à toi parce que
ça me semble que ces coiffes avec son
argent puis les investissements ppi il
me semble que ça devrait être un dû de
la connaissance de base les puits des
trucs que tu n'arrives pas à 31 ans à 30
ans n'entend qu'eux puis que tu tu
réalises
quelque chose c'est tommy ton argent
nature réalisé plus tard que t'es con
qui était dans le champ par rapport
qu'est-ce qui se passe
moi ça m'a toujours flabbergasting j'ai
apris était qu un hélène meyer en chimie
sont leurs quatre merkel j'ai jamais su
comme le je te parle j'ai 31 ans je
pensais qu un celi gspot coiffe tu sais
quelle forme ça prend je sais même pas
été grandement genre ça fait pas
longtemps que j'ai appris c'est quoi le
mot rendement que ça servait à quoi les
tic c'est quoi ton parcours à toi qu'est
ce qui t'a amené vers cette connaissance
des finances le 1 quand tout est avocate
ouais je suis avocate de formation je
pratique en litige puis le sujet je les
dis tantôt j'ai 32 ans puis avant mes 28
ans j'avais aucune des litiges et je
passais pas mon argent j'ai commencé à
mettre un petit peu d'argent de côté
mais je serai pas exactement comme toi
je savais pas quoi faire avec je pensais
qu'il y avait juste sèche avec ont peu
investi en bourse mais je pensais que tu
étais pas accessible à tous ce sont
aussi ces gamins qui l'a la bourse et
comme goa wall street le qui se réveille
le matin concernant les daaf
les écrans et craint que les numéros il
faut que je commence on espère un
langage qui comme quasiment du mandarin
pour moi quelque chose comme des
lumières
la matrice
a toujours été subie il ya encore
aujourd'hui j'ai comme le feeling c'est
cette fête continue ce qui me dépanner
ou qui vont à zéro
jusqu'à mes gestes est plus compliqué
investi en bourse en raison je pense
dans le temps nos parents t il fallait
encore appeler un broker sans courtier
au téléphone qui achètent souvent ça
c'était beaucoup moins que c'est mais là
tu es depuis les
15 dernières années surtout avec toute
l'énergie qu'on a ben si c'est vraiment
démocratique tout le monde a accès et si
on verra à
omar chehbour s'il se sert à voir
quelques clics de souris
avec la baule d'enfants
qui à 28 ans j'ai reçu une somme
d'argent je savais pas quoi faire avec
puis ces jeux toujours
plus marquée qu'en qui j'aime ça bien
faire les choses j'aime sommes
renseignés j'aime ce savoir si c'est que
la meilleure façon pour moi de com
s'est placé cet argent là parce que je
savais juste que si je le dépense je
leur ai pu faire que c'est pas ça le but
fait que je me suis mis à lire comme une
des français g j'ai beaucoup lu j'ai
beaucoup lu et j'ai pu beaucoup écouter
les podcasts qui m j aime
ça a était quoi excuses
j'ouvre une parenthèse c'était quoi
m'attendre d'été lecture ou des podcasts
qui ont été écrits mettant dans ton
apprentissage dans le secteur marques et
maintenant celui de ph mais
les deux
leaders mais
juste pour les gens qui nous écoutent
voudrait faire la main
pour les écoutes en ce moment ph est en
train d'ouvrir un
cessez-le-feu thq ou 100 km
donc les milliards les millionnaires ne
sont pas ce que vous croyez de nicolas
bérubé les éditions de la presse
donc ce livre là ça a été un des livres
qui te pour quelles raisons mais en fait
j'avais déjà des connaissances mais
c'était bien de l'est parce que je te
demande si tu le dis tous les
millionnaires ne sont pas ce que vous
croyez
qu'ils lui je m'excuse pour
lui ce qu'il dit c'est qu'il ya
interviewé plusieurs québécois dans
exsangue il y en a mais qui ont jamais
gagné t il gagner en 35is en mai at il
n'est jamais il si on peut gagner le
tour si travaillait pas y'a pas de juger
exactement et ont quand même réussi à
s'y mettre l'agent coûté pied bien vivre
ce qui explique comment est ce que cette
arrivée puis beaucoup concernent la dent
que j'aime
je m'émeus c'est sûr que je voulais je
les conserve toute personne qui en
augmente et c'est facile à l'air si ce
qu'ils disent est très pratique il ya
une sorte un 2ème aussi le fait qu'au
mans 2-0 a millionaire comment investir
en bourse en ce frais
15h39 ça il faut acheter son deuxième
[Rires]
période commence à aller mieux adhérer
c'est vraiment de quoi sur puis qu'est
ce qui ressort de ces lectures de ses
podcasts le
bo début j'ai aussi une light ji
interview est trop 24 financier parce
que j'avais aucune connaissance c'est
comme si je
ne
sais pas comment faire
fax et c'est ça la première étape j'ai
posé beaucoup de questions faire à ma
planificatrice puis encore aujourd'hui
je pose quand même des questions puis
pour valider ce que ce que je sais
je mais ce que je dis ça après ce
c'était quoi les premiers move qui te
fait maintenant nous intéressait c'était
en 2018 qui
de mémoire j'ai pas investi par moi même
avant
2019 donc j'ai quand même lu beaucoup
par moi même avant de
2,24 et financière at elle dit
écouter le son est exact qui a apprécié
décidé de commencer à
toi même décidé d'un cas les actions sur
les mettons l'argent petit et j'ai agi
en m après un an j'ai ouvert un compte
de courtage traite en ligne avec ma
banque qui j'ai commencé à placer un
petit peu par mois -
choisir des fonds et des actions puis
ces choix là tu faisais comme un parent
ce mois-ci mettons j'ai encore une fois
je prends mon exemple gérard bouchard
regarderai les logos des compagnies
fréquemment ces beaux quartiers fecteau
camacho dès ce week-end ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'en font comme un tipi pour
quelles raisons c'est quoi tes
indicateurs ce que tu es là également
des jeux vraiment
comme
qu'est ce qu'il faut regarder qu'est ce
qu'il faut regarder de manquer il ya
tellement d'indicateurs c'est moi
j'avais quatre fois que je vais lire les
états financiers je vais les reste que
les compagnies 10 dans les livres porte
mais il ya tellement d'autres
indicateurs
mais sauf que moi j'ai investi beaucoup
dans les compagnies que jamais que les
gays j'utilisais bancaires dans lesquels
tu croyais pas les quelques mois je
croyais mais si tu vois c'est quelque
chose que moi je pense que je pourrai
plus facilement
embarquer ici parce que commencer à
tomber dans ce genre la prospection de
quelque chose j'ai aucune idée d'une
compagnie minière en argentine
parce que les chiffres sont bons mais
ton 60 créerait beaucoup d'anxiété et
anti émeute ont de fait pas d'investir
d'un gourou parce que c'est une
compagnie québécoise que
je conçois moi même que je trouve cool
l'encouragent et il me semble que
j'embarquais plus la demande si je serai
plus capable de faire ce don mais ça
veut pas dire que ces gages dessus
j'imagine mais en fait c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui pensent
qu'elle va rembourser devoir choix faire
du stock picking c'est absolument
choisir si les actions alors que c'est
pas sortir des fonds je demande une
photo des fonds parce qu'il ya déjà j'ai
pas des dizaines milliers d'actions qui
sont à l'intérieur du stock picking
pièce a amorti aussi beaucoup ton reste
parce que si on se rappelle de nortel la
meute ont vu c'est assez vieux pour vous
rappeler que moi tu es les gens qui ont
perdu l'argent dans nortel parce qu'ils
y ont concentré leurs investissements
dans nortel
primates ont ils ont mis tout l'argent
qu'ils avaient à l'étape 4 soit plus
lente et va s'étaler de jean 120 dollars
à comme quelques soul parce qu'on
appelle il ya eu de la fraude
l'accent est à 0 mais ça c'est des
choses qui arrivent pas quand est bien
diversifié c'est sûrement quelque chose
que vous avez déjà entendu ce
qu'ils ont sur ce fameux trio l'an
dernier exactement anti fac c'est quoi
les chances que par exemple s'est
investi dans des gitans tout juste
parler du s&p 500 qui est un indice by
aussi des fonds négociés en bourse
qui suit cet indice lei donc aux rêveurs
qui dans le s p 500 500 fonds négociés
en bourse reproduit ce qui altère de mac
os google tous les 500 compagnies et
jesse 1 p 500 à l'intérieur de temps
dont sept enfants infectés pourtant la
question comme c'est quoi les chances
que tout ça en même temps ouais c'est
quand même peu probable ouais je
comprends du congrès avec ce genre de
fond là c'est ce qui est intéressant et
on contourne la personne ne veut un
temps qu'il veut investir 230 pièces par
mois ce genre de fond qui est
intéressant parce que sur le long terme
les chances ça tombe sont vraiment
fermées ce qui est recommandée dans les
livres en fait que que je sais fait par
le
putois d'alphonse et quand ils décident
de le faire toi même si tu penses que tu
penses karité connaissance tu peux
bâtir allemand le ou c'est juste fait
parce que tu aimes ce petit village est
ce parce que j'ai zappé les piles des
gens
j'en fais pas énormément
maintenant j + jeu plus dans les fonds
négocié en bourse et j'achète pis si je
lai je laisse mon argent
- parce que l'autre l'autre question
puis c'est moi maintenant j'ai la dame
zahra a donné moins mettre mon argent
dans quelque chose que j'ai pas pris le
temps vraiment d'analysé comme c'est
vraiment comme du monde j'ai jamais
vraiment embarqué dans l'écriture parce
que j'ai jamais pris la peine de checker
subi vraiment comprendre les systèmes
type tout puis
deux en me disant un temps fou que je
prenne tout ce temps là pour comprendre
comment ça fonctionne on dirait que je
me dis je vais prendre ce temps là pour
travailler à place puisse avoir un
meilleur rendement sur mes finances
personnelles que d'investis que de
prendre le temps de comprendre
l'investissement tic fait que j'imagine
que quand même ce ratio le 2 combien de
temps faut combien d'efforts ça te prend
investir son argent fait métier mais ton
oui mais
mettons contacter te trouver
planificateur financier soit je te
disent ils si le ratio temps est
vraiment moins dit que tout ce qui
m'intéresse pour maryse ce que le
prendre la peine de vraiment content
comprendre et essayer de comprendre
qu'est ce que je suis c'est messi soit
parce que ça fait très attention
financier qui fait pour toi qui prends
tout seul
je peux aussi parce que le rendement sur
le c sur l'investissement taxation de la
fac tu es payé un petit code de ce que
tu investis mais après ceci fait
physiquement gagnant pitois au final
c'est a pris le temps de la pluie ce
sera dur
mais tu dis ça prend beaucoup de temps
mais je pense que celui là c'est lui qui
te prendra pourtant non après
avoir une bonne idée déjà une bonne de
ouais on dirait que c'est peut-être
parce que je vois sur trop groupe pas le
seul à voir c'est trop gros pour ce que
c'est l'été sam ccam étourdissant même
mondial est-il l'autre jour quand je
suis en train me manques sont vendus a
justement pensé à jean investir parce
que le pour la première fois de leur vie
ont ensuite marché du travail depuis une
couple d'années pillon de l'argent d'un
surplus que tout le monde commence à
parler de leur argent et raquel fonds
pim logique de the game a paniqué quand
on est un des plus chers d'or pour
respirer les
dacquois j'imagine je pas le seul la
situation là puis est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui a fait que tu as décidé après c'est
de vouloir vulgariser ce avec la page
instagram parce que justement je me se
rendre compte qu'il y avait beaucoup de
personnes tamouls comme toi comme moi il
ya quatre ans que
je m'étais tellement senti
sait comment sont ma part ça mais j'ai
28 ans commence à j qui
ont dit que le message qu'on nous envoie
ses bêtes au 23 août
exposer sa
voix en même temps mais pareillement la
paperie l'école monge à mépriser j'ai
fait un pas que je ne maîtrise jamais
après ça commence et c'est comme ça
une part de moi qui sentait qu est très
injuste
puis je voulais faire quelque chose à
mon niveau à mon âme à façon pour
changer ça parce que je le faisais déjà
mes amis donc je faisais déjà des petits
copains des finances à xavier fait quand
william écocentres hiver culte
aujourd'hui face à va bien
puis j'ai toujours aimé vulgariser les
concepts sont un peu plus complexes même
pendant le bac je refaisais puis avant
les examens on faisait des crackers fait
que je savais que j'étais capable de
faire ça
puis instagram mais parce que c'est les
gens lisent de moins en moins on veut
puis instagram je trouve que c'est une
belle plateforme tg karma côté
esthétique j'ai je sais comment
présenter l'information des images accès
je me disais que j'allais pas être
capable de parler à aux gens autrement
parce que je trouvais que souvent on
nous cherche on ne sait pas ce qu'on
sait pas d'étude vrai faciliterait
surtout aux femmes le t on cela a été
fait j'ai coupé dans la fin août et si
tu achetais pas ton café et aurait
peut-être un condo watch comme les maths
qui on s'entend
fait qu'il ya beaucoup ça c'est vraiment
en fait se rendent mission sociale
jusqu'au puits et une raison pourquoi te
décider
s'adresser principalement parce que
c'est un public cible quand on va sur ta
page maintenant on s'aperçoit que c'est
plus petit a expliqué aux femmes puis
c'est quoi le king day as le ting ting
ce que je voulais parler à moi meilleur
mais quand j'avais pas cette ses
connaissances le pas
exactement parce que je sais en étant
une femme qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
femmes qui sont comme moi puis je me
disais
fait
naïvement bataille que je te serai
capable de leur parler parce que comme
vous j j je me sens comme a franchi 2
c'est
mesquin titi que
on
on prend pour acquis que c'est des
choses qu'on devrait savoir le tome peut
vraiment raison parce que je me rappelle
pas d'une conversation que j'ai entendu
ou de
podcasts ou dans un entrevue j'ai
entendu ou est ce que on a pris la peine
de m'expliquer c'était quoi derrière m
suivant l'exemple des meilleurs parce
que mes parents parler des reér entre
eux qui avaient mis de l'argent alors
erreur puis par le derrière pirée r ça
revenait souvent peut-être trop souvent
même comme dans dans ma vie le trt-5
jamais j'ai eu une crise id de steckel
puisse cette dynamique là évolué jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant le tir puis encore
revenir là dessus mais moi je je
comprends pas pourquoi ça ne pas être
expliquées avant l'étude comment ça
s'est perdu dans l'est dans les craques
le tir parce que j'ai encore une fois je
suis loin d'être le seul dans cette
situation lâche sur le dessus et fait je
suis d'accord avec toi que d'avoir une
page comme ceci s'arrête beaucoup le tir
c'est quoi les les publications de fait
qui ont fait le plus réagir sur ta page
puisqu'elle était le sujet des
publications ton pour entrer dans ces
sujets de
sur la mesure ben ça lui dit
millionnaire
les gens beaucoup aimé celui leurs
efforts à quel âge tu réponds que c'est
quand le montant
qu'il y avait quelque chose dans ce
poste clôt aussi le au delà de 20 ans 30
ans est venu celui d'un petit peu plus
loin que c'était si tu disais
investir 120 dollars par mois pardon
puis devenir millionnaire à 30 50 et 120
dollars par mois qu'après 10 ans ça
paraît beaucoup sur quelques adhérentes
à 30 ans puis ton investissement est
encore 220 dollars dont 6 rien fait
l'importance d'enseigner parce que tu en
parles aussi dans cette publication là
l'importance d'enseigner
les finances à ses enfants
je pense que c'est assez considérable
comment qu'on fait ça et que je sais pas
par où en étais je veux pas mieux sur
des ressources et en sommes je pense
dans le sur l'application ouais ça va
plus cassant je parlais de là je me suis
un petit parc à thème
je me souviens pas parce qu'un faudrait
que vous allez vous le monde iront voir
sur le
puits ce que j'ai répondu à une question
qui
en fait j'aurais continué dessus sur une
application et un fils il y avait un
sim et on attend que parra replacé ses
pensées 2000 km dans un conte pour votre
enfant
une fois mais avec la naissance de
l'enfant avec un rendement de je pense
que c'est autour de 10% votre avant
votre mine la 65e fait que ces fous en
fait le pouvoir du long terme
c'est vraiment le mot clé c'est
exponentiel télérama parce que fils
ton argent produit durant ma vie
d'enfant le roman se fait sur l'argent
plus le rendement est factice et le
savons il m'a un peu la difficulté à
comprendre les romans exponentielle mais
c'est j'aime beaucoup paris les
simulations sur l'outil calculateur
d'être est composé des gobelets seul
puis vous allez pour m
combien j'ai investi par mois ht mathon
simulant un taux d'intérêt de 7 %
et après tu aimes tant d'années mais ça
va donner tel montant qui ça me surprend
tout le temps à quel point si c'est
énorme énorme qui si tu joues avec tes
la différence de 20 30 ans et c'est
énorme comme différence parce que je
t'aime en empruntant taux cumulé
beaucoup de rendement qu'il a su tu
ajoutes un autre disant attend 20 ans
mais le
stoppeur monsieur jeune quand même et on
pourrait pour quelqu'un comme moi le
type qui a jamais
eu un luis le thé dans ma vie mais
jamais de ce moniteur est dans mon
compte chèques lire ce que je faisais du
sport université je travaillais pas
quinze sorties et le marché du travail
s'est pas guère rachid vendu avec un
qu'une maîtrise en littérature le triste
pour quelque chose qui permet d'aller
chercher un job assuré fait que de voir
le temps passer et d'entendre des
affaires comme ça maintenant c'est quand
même ce gène pour pour la suite des
choses mettez y en même temps je me gêne
quilles jamais trop tard sont alors je
n'y ai jamais trop tôt plus il ya un
proverbe dans ce livre qui dit il le
meilleur qui suivront là c'est vraiment
vraiment là le meilleur moment pour
porter un homme s'il ya 20 ans mais le
deuxième maire moment
on peut jamais rattraper le temps perdu
mais j'avais un peu ce sentiment là à 28
ans je te marché comme si j'ai 28 ans et
des gens qui ont commencé à 8 ans mais
là comment je vais faire
avec les intérêts dans ma vie ou ce que
je mettais si je me limitais beaucoup
pigeons je mettais quand même beaucoup
d'argent côté plus qu'aujourd'hui le par
rapport à ce que je fais mes frères
salah aujourd'hui 2415 avec thomas mais
finalement j'ai aujourd'hui je me
restreins beaucoup moins quelque chose
que j'aime j'avais fait à l'époque à
cause de la chose que tu des vosges a
rappelé le temps perdu
ptt apprécié pour toujours des raisons
qui lui demande son avis dans des
situations plus difficiles que d'autres
piketty y mettons j'étais tout à fait le
choix de faire du parti
dans la vie de mon titre de choses qui
se passent mais
y est tu t es ce que épargnés c'est
juste la sphère du monde qui
qui font beaucoup d'argent ou peu
importe comment sur l'argent il de
manière d'épargner qui mais je pense que
quand même une manière d'épargner
puisque le livre rédigé trouve que ça
donne beaucoup de sport parce que
donner exemple des gens qui font pas des
gros salaires mais il y avait quand même
l'argent de côté ce soit que je connais
pas votre situation mais tout ne serait
ce que ouvrir un compte puis même m même
investir 22 heures par semaine c'est
quand même quelque chose que je pense
c'est quand même peut-être possible mais
n'a mené par des gens puis est ce que
toi ou est ce que quand il parle à des
amis c sipa comment qu'on y arrive je me
gêne c'est en faisant un budget puis en
en ayant en partant de son savoir à
pitre si je veux y arriver il faut que
je mette en pire journée en ce dernier
mois c'est j'aime beaucoup le concept
payez en premier parce que ce que je
fais à chaque pays un montant qui est
automatiquement prélevée de mon compte
chèques qui est automatiquement investis
dans les marchés boursiers étaient
automatiquement chaque match que tu
reçois de ton travail il ya un peu moins
d'un revirement qui fait de ton contrat
quand on conduit de prélèvement qui se
fait payer c'est ça que je conseille aux
gens parce que sinon je ne vois même pas
passé je pense que c'est comme un
paiement sur l'occasion je ne considère
pas dans l'argent disponible pour aller
au resto non parce que tiges esprit
j'espère que c'est peu facile c'est une
fois que tu le fais c'est facile j'ai
commencé à face à un peu plus que quatre
ans puis d'enfants c'est cool parce que
c'est une bonne descente dû prendre mais
c'est pour la vie c'est gentil s'arrête
jamais c'est un petit club et c'est bon
pour l'invité
n'est pas dit qu'ils écoutent kiseki
combien qui serait possible dans ma
réalité
de dire mettons peut-être que je me
privais d'une sortie par mouawad erreurs
mais que je peux investir dans dans un
confort un virement automatique dati
puis quand on le voit même montré que ça
devient tout d'un coup plus possible
mais aussi que samedi on a beaucoup
talence a budgété selon ce qu'ont été
fatigante on compte un suspense moyens
voici ce que c'est quelque chose que je
commençais deux frères depuis
tes avant justement je faisais ce chèque
à la fin de l'année je travaillais foule
puis si je dépensais pas trop pis j'y
allais un pur friestad t'as faim tu me
reste à fait que jamais temps de côté
maintenant je visite et au lieu de deux
le fait d'un d'un gros coup tu es ou si
mal fait ou fera maintenant fait que
j'ai un montant comme tu dis à chaque
mois - kippa claque puis après ce que je
pense pas quand je regarde mon compte
c'est ce petit jeu c'est pas de l'argent
que je me dis ok belgique en fait que je
vais aller m'acheter si vous n'en est
pas là c'est ça c'est ça la différence
quand même 2 tu fais ton budget à partir
de ce que de la turquie tristesse qui
tresse d'après la place de la phase avec
ce que toki rang puis je suis un buteur
pourcentage clim est temps que que les
gens dans dans ce domaine le bon dieu
qui faute de paris tel pourcentage de
ton revenu ou mais on entend souvent 10%
mais je trouve que c'est peu quand ses
enfants max pas tout le monde qui veut
prendre sa retraite à 65 ans il ya des
gens qui étaient qui parle du poste pour
la retraite aussi parce que c'est pas
mieux dit j'ai déjà eu la question avait
été vu que théo gouvernementaux déjà un
fonds de pension pourquoi est ce que tu
veux épargner des proches mais pourtant
investi alors que ta retraite est déjà
assurée moi qui parle tenant par la main
répond c'est parce que peut-être un jour
pas arrêter de travailler sur une
variante que je veux prendre une année
sabbatique un moment donné parce que
c'est un moment donné je voudrais
changer d'emploi notamment
la liberté que ça peut procurer c'est
d'avoir l'argent côté ou juste pour la
4è des porteurs de projets qui confère
j'ai vu une publication aussitôt fait
c'était par rapport aux voyages dans ce
pays
il ya mettons comprend les voyages comme
porte d'entrée vers ce sujet le
large en une valeur aujourd'hui
maintenant c'est et puis elle une valeur
puis une valeur de l'investissement pays
qui a le vraiment un aspect mais
financiers qui existent quiquine
facilement calculable maintenant mais
l'argent aujourd'hui
prends mon cas début trentaine aussi une
valeur au-delà de son chiffre qui est de
pouvoir vivre des expériences de pouvoir
prenons les voyages de pouvoir voyager
maintenant quand j'ai encore des genoux
fonctionnel plus que capables d'aller
courir maintenant en espagne toujours
donner cet exemple j'ai aucune des six
ce que je referai mais mettons d'aller
courir en espagne
salo quand même une valeur puis comment
est ce qu'on fait pour
évaluer ce versus évaluer des
investissements parce que je compte
mettons que de prendre
j'ai pas 2000 bias pour aller courir en
espagne aujourd'hui maintenant versus
l'investir
c'est comme un choix qui est vraiment
off pour moitié prix même qu' il y ait
un post it off que sorte que parlement
que j'irai courir l'espagne c'est
aujourd'hui maintenant comment est-ce
qu'on réconcilie l'espèce de mentalité
yolo de notre génération des milléniaux
puis d'aider des générations qui s'en
viennent
versus une mentalité plus cartésienne
investissements pour penser à son futur
du considérant qu ce qu'on investit dans
on a parlé ou au dîner on investit dans
un futur inconnue la place de prendre
l'argent dans le présent connu tu sais
comment est-ce qu'on réconcilie soit si
tout est ce que tu penses un peu est ce
que tu te fais jardin un genre de juste
milieu est ce que serait un juste milieu
puis comme je dis au début début de
monts et
merveilles financiers
je me privais beaucoup parce que
je voulais rattraper le temps perdu mais
j'ai réalisé que ce n'était pas pour moi
comme je peux pas vivre comme je peux
pas vivre avec 35 $ par année à deux pas
possible
fabien conte sexe en investissement qui
s'appelle le coup de renoncer à son
actif par exemple le 2002 alors que tu
apprends l'espagne peut te demander mais
comme le domaine d'en laure qu'est ce
que c'est à quoi je renonce dans le fond
en allant le lez beaulieu de l'investir
parce que tu es c'est correct de tout ce
que j'aime le concept de ce pays en
premier parce que étant donné que je
veux ce pays en premier mais le reste je
vais le dépenser et le témoin pas de
sentir mal de penser parce que tu es pas
renier une partie parce que je n'ai pas
rien investi une partie d'enfants moi
j'ai pagne 20 % de mon être revenu de
mon être
puis ça c'est sans compter que j'ai
aussi des anges rembourse mon hypothèque
ne pigez
tech pour épargner plus mais je me dis
tiens j'ai quand même envie de profiter
d'un moment j'en étais je travaille fort
je n'ai pas envie de vivre comme
d'ailleurs
pour terminer comme ça
puis le coup de renonciation d'enfants
comment tu les value c'est que tu dis
mais tant qu'ils m'ont 2000 pièces
maintenant donne sur et mettons dans nos
langues
4000 bien mais en fait elle l'exemple de
découvrir les sang et or ne s'est
peut-être pas un bon exemple parce que
tu es ça procure vraiment je pense une
expérience pire
c'est beaucoup de bonheur et de joie le
dandy line massé lui si on peut donner
l'exemple par exemple café chez
starbucks qui met les purs encore cause
la pandémie le métier par exemple les
gens c'est un automatisme d'acheter un
même deux cafés par jour tous les gens
travaillent centre-ville mais ça le coup
de renonciation de ça c'est que m'étant
10 dollars même dans le livre en parle
et est investi 15 europe par joe à 20 en
mai à 52 ans il y en a à raconter je me
souviens pas c'est quoi le rendement
est petit c'est clair qu'il ya mis le
temps mais
quinze heures par jour ça va vite quand
même prendre un café tous demandent non
à l'extra guacamole et genre une soupe
cuisinée un riz aux légumes au lieu de
commander
ce lundi
avant mon année j'avais fait il heurte
repartir sur autre chose parce que
l'argent c'est tellement j'avais fait
une semaine on était deux on avait mangé
pour 50 pièces puis on avait acheté 50
pièces de bouffe
c'est parfait on avait acheté on avait
un billet de 50 dollars puis on avait
devant faire l'épicerie une fois on va
acheter la bouffe puis on va essayer de
cuisiner déjeuner dîner souper avec 50
pièces pour 2 fait 25 pièces la personne
ou peut-être grand test pour moi vrai
piège pour et puis on avait réussi puis
nous en restait après la semaine puis
c'est qu'en
l'espèce de conteur françois lambert
avait parlé de son épicerie action de 15
pièces pour l'ubs ces deux groupes le
tout le monde l'avait traité de menteur
tu ne manges marc de millionnaires qui
se pensent bon après c'est philippe
couillard était sorti en disant vraiment
que ça se peut plus tout le monde capoté
mais crise mais je l'avais fait je
mettais pas priver le on était allé
évidemment moi je suis végétalien fait
que ça coûte déjà de base vraiment -
charles le bloc 2 2 fut pour 2 2 49e
place de genre et de filets de poulet à
6 kg à cet effet que des jaloux tu sors
pas mal mais on était alité dans un maxi
des légumineuses sèche depuis ça nous a
pris plus de temps que je n'ai
maintenant une fruiterie des légumes de
deuxième main qu'ils rejetaient de
l'industrie que drama moins cher mais ça
nous a coûté 50 pièces puis depuis qu'on
a fait ce à chaque fois que je vois
l'épicerie c'est un coach en 15 81 cents
pièces puis je regarde tous genres
limite deux soupers puis des chips genre
du beurre de pinottes mettons
puis que je me dis je me dis ça serait
tellement facile de si je me donnait la
peine pour vrai lui d'économiser comme
du monde le dit
j'imagine que dans plein d'aspects de la
vie c'est de même aussi l'inde en pleine
affaire qu'on fait le quotidien on
pourrait vraiment on pourrait le
meilleur en même temps quelque chose de
l'fun juste manger ce que satan de
manger mais on s'était même pour priver
tant que juste le reflet c'est que je
sais
c'est ce qu'on dépense en fait je
voudrais pas ce que c'est il ya beaucoup
de nos dépenses que celle automatisée je
le fais parce que j'ai toujours fait pis
si on réfléchis pas vraiment b c'est
quoi le coup de renonciation à ce que le
cafi que j'achète par jour ascame
m'apporte tellement de la commune
passion café
take my money mais c'est autrement
évalue les dépenses à savoir si est ce
que c'est vraiment de façon
consciencieuse se dépense le maho
vraiment du bonheur et peut-être une
autre façon quelques lycées occupés tout
le temps je peux tu vas t'acheter un
blender parce que
tu peux aussi
/ le coût d'utilisation enfants en fait
les soldes si je m'assume chez moi mais
ça me coûtait 26 lieu de l'acheter tout
fait déjà acté ce titre
quelques mots avec l'étude des dépenses
que toi tu juges qui sont
plus faciles à couper ou qui sont
vraiment - le gecko est sensé et
personnellement moi la bouffe mais ça
c'est parce que je suis rampe à 17
heures j'aime tout je pensais me
demanderez samassa puel ont noté que ce
qui se dira la bouffe je parlerai
d'ouvrir les restos été jetés dans des
restos metidji pas besoin d'aller dans
les meilleurs
c'est ce que les restos sa conduite en
mode c'est les restos sont ses méthodes
souvent le père plus tu prend quelque
chose à boire c'est comme ces salles et
la fin versus cuisinier chez vous peut
avoir une aussi belle soit au risque en
cuisinant chez vous quand tu ouvres
entre devant la maison de ses pour
vraiment pas
vraiment aidé avant dans un resto fou
dans le vif des foules le pit et j'ai
l'impression que ces sites
ces trois communes des fois je regarde
ce thème et regarde ces photos le
montrant instagram sur quatre et les
amis pu laisser ça aux restos s'asseoir
au bord je me dis
ce soit ces gens là vivent au dessus de
leurs moyens ou soit ils font descendre
un bon sens que moi je pourrais pas me
permettre de l'or aller au resto
aujourd'hui bon resto à bouteilles de
vin est triste mais pas de beaucoup de
personnes qui vivent au dessus de leurs
moyens ça c'est sur le coup puis j'avais
aussi parlé de sa sphère un moment mais
les trois dépenses qui
contribuent à leur niveau de bonheur il
ya une étude qui avait fait part qui
avait été fait pendant par des
chercheurs de business school qu'ils
aient des enfants il est trop dépenses
qui par joyce et
l'argent qu'on dépense par des
expériences dont des voyages qui fait
entre autres les chercheurs existe parce
que peut-être on a souvent tendance à se
comparer dit en étant humain puis les
expériences par contre peu moins comparé
l'auto ton loto avec celui du voisin que
ton voyage à paris jeudi si toi que le
vécu c'est peut pas vraiment comparer à
ce cadeau parce que c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est l'argent
qu'on dépense sur les autres parce que
tu es en créant un lien social en ayant
l'impression que tu payes ton prochain
peut-être que
non un style au restaurant puis le 3 à
dépenser là dépend une dépense pour
avoir plus de temps c'est par exemple
pouvoir l'aménager ou par rapport
à préparer parce que ça fond étant donné
qu'on est des aides sociales puis qu'on
aime se passer du temps avec nos proches
des livres se libérer du temps mais ça
nous permet de faire
cesser les trois dépenses qui
contribuent
généralement au bonheur à long terme -
fait qu'avoir un char de l'année par
exemple c'est pour dans les trous qui
vont pâtir et brice ça va être
parce que je peux donner un conseil
financier
gentil guay can absolument rien si vous
êtes pour louer une voiture pendant
quatre ans à celui d'avoir le même
revenu pendant quatre ans parce que si
vous pensé louer une voiture avec en
payant à chaque deux semaines à un
moment dans votre vie ou es ce que vous
avez une bonne rentrée monétaire que
dans deux langues trois ans plus tard là
les rentrées monétaire pour échouer y
raisons diminue ou ou s'évapore mais
vous avez quand même le même paiement à
chaque deux semaines qui rendent parce
que vous avez pris une décision qui
était à ce moment là dans vos moyens
mais qui définitivement maintenant
toutes vos moyens faites attention à ça
mais de là aussi l'intérêt imagine mais
d'épargné comme c'est le cas des actifs
dans ces moments là où est ce que tu
fais un peu plus mais ça s'utilise ne
pas semer que ça va en rester là mais
tant pis pour que si ça arrive
tandis que ça mais justement j'attendais
je pense que les périmètres swing qui
le pire en pire gouffre et argent tu
sais qui tu peux te permettre d'aller de
la voiture de classement le prix de la
voiture comme telle
pilule le golf mais en fait lui on peut
parler du coût de renonciation enfants
en donnant l'exemple de pee wee
lui il ya 10
10 a toujours conduit des chars de marne
commune a qu'une vieille acquéreurs qui
relaie pendant vraiment longtemps mais
là il s'est dit que je me souviens pas
si je l'avais écouté la radio entre que
may au doute et à 40 par mois j'ai je
m'achète une audi puis mais nous 10
secondes mais je pense que ça gueulait à
j'avais toujours à tout le monde
je me suis alors j'ai confiance les
joueurs qu'est ce que j'ai vu du haut
point bas mais
le coup de renonciation c'est que moi j
j'aime j'ai pas acheté de belles
voitures pendant jusqu'à mes 40 ans puis
à mes 40 ans bévue que la vue que j'ai
investi cet argent là à la place comme
si les allemands ont un peu comme jean
s'est passée sans qu'on nous cache
ses seuls coups de renonciation qu'ils
partent tenter d'y manger on sait à ça
j'ai conduit dévié autres pendant
longtemps bec c'est ce qui m'a permis de
mettre l'argent côté puis finalement
machine aux dix secondes mains
d'enfants de cathy les calculs ou final
c'est le sacrifice
que je fais aujourd'hui
dans futures vont être dit mettons ce
que ce que je peux me payer grâce et en
faisant sacrifice tout ce que je me paye
peut dans le futur jeu pour me payer
dépendamment du temps et quatre fois se
désaxer c'est est ce que je veux un
petit un plus petit plaisir ou un petit
h maintenant ou un plus gros dans le sur
ses sauts finalement le petit frère
d'ange les pipes une des raisons
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a beaucoup de
difficulté à se projeter à la retraite
c'est que c'est tellement loin qu'on
notre savoir la difficulté à penser que
c'est nous mais on taxe et
que je me suis un peu à ce que j'avais
vu ou lu je pense que cette
documentation et flex et qu'ils y ont
branché les gens avec les
pays regardez lille y analyse ali
cerveau des gens lapide enfants
ils ont vu que lyon
contre expliquer ce
qu
il veut aussi un projet toi à 65 ans
mais comme ces personnes là c'était
comme un étranger pour moi la personne
active fait pas vraiment et c'est pour
ça que
épargner pour la retraite pour un
étrange
cette déconnexion les 100% de me dire
qu'il tient dans 30 ans qui va
bénéficier de ce qu'ils me demandent de
moi qui me prive aujourd'hui alors que
c'est quand c'est moi dans 30 ans mais
ce sera son problème à lui
mais quatre mois mais dont
les parents que je mets loge
présentement je la vois plus comme ce
qui va me permettre d'acheter une
première propriété ne tombe plus que la
retraite a compris que tout d'un coup ça
devient plus concret et puis plus plus à
moyen terme tant la nuit
moi ce serait personnellement sur et
même ça c'est sûr que ça c'est sûr que
ça s'ancre plus dans ta réalité pis mais
encore une fois t2 de penser que
l'investissement si c'est mieux sur le
long terme comme une contradiction dans
ce que tu
écoutes pitois par l'ajustement de
l'immobilier est ce que pour toi c'est
quelque chose qui dans la vie de
quelqu'un qui a investi ou qui veut
s'assurer une retraite si tu as un
incontournable où s'est tue quelque
chose qu'on aurait visé ou pas
nécessairement ou est-ce qu'il ya moyen
d'être locataire puis très attendue
concernant comment tu vois ça il ya
moyen de l'acaata depuis 13 ans santé
financièrement type justement
les deux auteurs des livres que je dois
faire mais on y prend l'investissement à
la bourse
personnellement j'ai seulement ma maison
comme biens immobiliers j'ai peur
je peux annoncer ça m'était c'est pas un
incontournable dans le sens que je pense
que tu peux atteindre liberté financière
sans être propriétaire sans avoir des
immeubles à revenus oui je pense que
c'est un bon moyen mais sauf que c'est
moi personnellement je peux manu est
factice à dépendre du type personne
aussi à ce que tu goûtes de t'investir
est-ce que tu eu le goût de faire de
reno et que tu le good deal et avec des
lakas passe et tout sera dit c'est
vraiment que l'effet de levier vraiment
intéressant dans le domaine du prêt
c'est avoir dix mille dollars puis
acquérir un bien je peux je dis
n'importe quoi là 150000 si l'effet
levier qui est vraiment intéressante et
par exemple si j'investis dix mille
dollars à la bourse puis à 10% mais
j'aime dans ce que tu dis mille dollars
investir dans l'immobilier 8e des dettes
le pilote se voient rembourser une
hypothèque m
tu as quand même permis d'acquérir un
bien qui est comme beaucoup moi plus que
ton dignité sauf que
gestion de la capa gestion de l'east
river ces expériences a pas de dégâts
d'autres c'est sur la toile que je
mangeais personnellement pas envie de
casser la tête avec c'est un choix
personnel pige pas du tout j'ai pas du
tout sur les gens qui
m'aimait mais ça fait un moment que ça
soit un duplex ou un triplex que le fait
d'avoir une maison
c'est un investissement ce que son
investissement soit mais là ça va
dépendre à qui tu poses la question
pendant qu'elle paierait pas ce que
c'était par me tourne aux paroles dans
les années 80-90 les taux d'intérêts
très élevés les maisons les prix des
maisons ont stagné pendant très très
longtemps le fait même que yoyo la basse
saxe à des pentes et je pense que ces
accords est que de se comparer avec
juste ce qu'on a vécu les dernières
années pizza qui belles heures ça prend
20 % par année c'est sûr que ça mon
placement n'ont pas toujours ça serait
pas toujours s'appuie le theux vue on
est en train de vivre
on voit que des cendres simplement je
pense que jean martin est le dilemme et
c'est intimement liés aux taux d'intérêt
dans le fond parce qu'elle plus le taux
d'intérêt faible plus les gens ont pour
d'empereur parce que donc aussi plus les
gens vendent leur maison chars parce
qu'ils disent les gens parce que les
gens sont agréables de bsb dont un prix
à un prix plus élevé puis tandis que le
silo à ce moment là tout l'intérêt de
remonter donc les prix des maisons bon
normalement c'est un indicateur très
inversée inversément inversement
proportionnel
je suis pas là encore ne permet tait les
demandes de tout cela c'est dans le fond
normalement quand tu es là quand tu
loues quelque chose beta moins de
dépenses qu'un propriétaire s'était pas
de taxe de bienvenue et pas de taxe
annuelle t'as pas de taxes scolaires
tapas ya beaucoup de dépenses
récurrentes que tu ne peux te paye un
loyer c'est sa queue
leu leu quelques la force et bombay est
ce que je suis capable d'épargner la
différence entre le mot court comme
locataire puis mon cou comme
propriétaire et
le je sais qu'il ya des gens qui doutent
des condos sont retrouvés dans l'eau
pour moi si je voudrais ce site fait ça
versus quelqu'un qui a une maison qui
paie une hypothèque mais c'était un peu
mieux mais tu sais si tu es capable de
trouver un logis qui ça coûte moins cher
que quelqu'un qui a une maison mais que
tu t'investis la bourse a cédé quoi sont
que les gens 82
ouais parce que moi l'audio je me disais
aussi tic en compagnie de mobilier chez
les métaux moi je paye mille deux cent
cinquante pièces par mois pour pour mon
appart kaki
juste en dehors je pense pour un trois
et demi mettons nous à l'époque dans
lequel on vit tu vas être situé en ville
puis le jeta québec fait que montréal
ajoutant 200 pièces à sion puis le je me
disais maintenant je m'en acheter
quelque chose dans le condo qui à 400
milles de ton 500 milles où 350 1000
mètres 2 puis mon hypothèque serait 1900
béton je me dis maintenant cassure parce
que moi je me disais dans le fond mais à
la place de payer 1250 je vois payé 1200
puis je veux je vais avoir de quoi à
moitié mais quand j'y repense et je fais
moi même peut-être que le move à place
parce que moi je suis 0 manuel g aucune
fatigue a envie de me tracasser avec des
travaux à faire c'est que tout ce qu'il
juge appelle quelqu'un qui vient de
régler ce chez nous je déblais pont
entre était tout seul je me disais après
que le move à place de faire ce c'est
prendre la différence je l'investis
la maison c'est l'époque force et
passion c'est obligé c'est obligé il ya
beaucoup de moments sympas que sont pas
bons avec points ses seules écoles
j'essaie d'arriver à un spot diakite
cheikh mo loyers non mon loyer ses 2000
pièces par mois même si tu payes 1250
mètres mais 750 cases de côté par mois
mais top 10 seuls je sais pas le calcul
se ferait comment mais j'imagine ce
repas est ici loin que d'acheter
une maison
cette simulation la danse ou google qui
tue
il ya quand même une bonne séance parce
que tu es il ya beaucoup de dépenses non
récupérables dans une maison des crimes
et on te fait un gain je peux juste
n'importe quoi là de 100 milles après
cinq ans après dix ans comme ça quand
même envie tous les la toiture après 20
ans qui coûte dix mille places à faire
faire finir le sous-sol les intérêts que
tu perds la banque et par les taxes
c'est tous les départs les chasseurs
préfère voit jamais dans tous ses actes
et spe toujours fait que c'est pas si
clair que ce que si comme c'est parce
que moi j'entendais le mondial le ticket
non mais qui disait l'immobilier c'est
la chose la plus sûre bien vite ministre
là dedans mais quand tu veux quand tu
réalises que finalement la différence
que tu payes pas une hypothèque pour
l'investir puis servi qu'à ce moment ce
n'est pas le cas que d'une maison c'est
quand même inquiet c'est pas ce genre
c'est pas une si mauvaise pose une
ciconne décision de rester locataire
mettons le paquet qu'un qui n'ont rien à
faire d'avoir une maison où je connais
des gens aussi qui sont locataires
eux-mêmes mais qui ont des
investissements immobiliers
ça aussi c'est quelque chose ok c'est ça
il ya des investissements immobiliers
mais aussi
par mois
date 7 qui récolte par contre plaidoyer
de plein de la capa l oeil on dit bien
les portes se sait pas c'est pas
seulement la faire la différence ce qui
m' au niveau des extraits sur mon loyer
si ce parce que comme tu dis et les
taxes
qui s'ajoute au fait d'être des
propriétaires qui le tact investir parce
qu'au final le temps c'est de l'argent
dedans c'est de l'argent puis pneus de
pouvoir aussi mouiller avec mes amis qui
m'ont toujours dit ça et si tu t'es là
14h tu paies aussi pour le droit de s'en
aller entre temps mettant demain un gros
crash immobilier insein pis que je suis
la catr je peux quand même déménagé je
n'ai pas de problème à vendre ma maison
à 200 mètres de moi je l'a achetée chez
juste porcine et mumbai pechmarty en un
an et personne ne me demande rien je
déménage pays date c'était réglé tu es
plus et flexible ouais ouais j'ai allumé
sur ce
point il ya cette flexibilité l'eau si
tu voulais courir en espagne
a décoré avec les faux ouais mais tu
sais moi c'est bon ça fait d'être très
simple un peu parce que moi l'immobilier
sam
l'immobilier investissement tout
ceci est anxiogène pour - l'immobilier
surtout c'est de voir qu'à 31 ans
mettant
ses larges aussi comme dit maintenant tu
compare avec les générations avant les
autres tu fais crise mais on dirait que
mentor dans le bateau le ti jean moins
un parent et camon part à 31 ans c'est
leur deuxième maison il ya qu un enfant
puis 15 mai mais c'est vrai que vu comme
ceux plus en plus mais je suis 0 manuel
gens de maison ça me fend le ridicule
vraiment ça me ferait chier l'entremise
de metz
ouais ouais on fait attention frais de
condo pas ce que c'est on peut se faire
baiser du
chèque trois fois plus dépensier coma
qui coule finalement ça mon hypothèque
ce possible et arrive le puits le
flamand et
il ya plus de production comme les frais
cachés de la location de l'édifice au
hasard comment elle voyait trois mille
3000 pièces par mois on est capable de
payer sur le tard et où les premiers
loyers 6 3
plus les cod taton très de condos vote
qu' il faut augmenter les frais de condo
pendant que tu viennes arriver le pis le
tout d'un coup tomber le double de temps
hypothèque en frais de condo nous met
une paie le même montant mais c'est
comme çà dire - classé myphone aussi
requis qu'elle logique ça c'est pour ça
pour les gens à la maison
citant loyer mathon mais le 200m haies h
assez d'acheter quelque chose qui va pas
de coûter plus que 1200 en tout et
partout le danton hypothèque ton hydro
des taxes c'est mort lâche d'un condo
récemment on a fait le calcul je pense
que son loyer si ton loyer 2002 sa
maintenance dont les 2200 tu veux
acheter quelque chose que tu on
hypothèque en était frais et tout va est
à 1200 mais et c'est que ça soit pas
loin de sauter va pas être pote acheter
quelque chose ou est ce que ça va te
coûter 2500 parce que le
trouver quelque chose à 1200
lâche un petit con doux quand on connaît
toutes rénovées et fatma sait se faire
parce que témoin mettons c'est quelque
chose que je commence à regarder le ton
puis trouver quelque chose que j'aurais
une hypothèque en plus des clés free qui
vient avec 2200
ccsl à trouver ouais même que tu vas les
vivats gaspin il fallait vivre dans un
genre de petites cabines à gaspé gaspé
de la pop
mais c'est sans qu'un mariage pas dans
quel point tu regardes mais ouais c'est
sûr que metz et c'est juste une ré
évidemment pour l'adapter à mes jeux
pour donner une idée et il va pas tu
acheté
votre prendre quelque chose qui a coûté
5000 pièces par la perchaude à faire
j'imagine 7e mettre la corde au cou l'
unité dans vie en général de faire une
dépense qui tenait la corde au cou
blessés comme genre faut je coupe tout
le reste venant
il disait qu'il y avait des ce même ami
que je parle je parlais tantôt il dit
qu'il y avait une pratique sur les
divorces puis les séparations ça arrive
en n 3 en ré pleine grande grande
majorité arrivant dans trois ans suivant
une grande grande dépense une grande
dépense financière un grand stress
financier part ça vient green tension de
gens sur le coup pied pas nécessaire du
tout le du bungert n quels sont pour
vous la traitez en cours comment vous
gérez votre argent puis si ça vous
dérange que l'autre gang est ce que vous
vous serez arrêtés forfait avec
quelqu'un qui gagne une quinte soit à la
hausse ou à la baisse
une si grande différence avec vous si je
récuse entendre une perspective de
bronze me tombe dessus
sur les questions de stress et comment
comment gérer votre argent que quand
vous êtes en cô moi j'étais encore en
développement
ça fait pas super longtemps
chacon de peau on n'a pas de compte
conjoint ou le pot de tous ceux mais
mettons dans le passé j'ai déjà eu un
compte conjoint avec mon ex m'a t-on
puis tous les dépenses qui étaient
mettons un parent soin apporté puisque
en gros c'était à pâtisserie
goûter avec tout ce qu'ils disent et
pensent qu'ils étaient vraiment comme
une séquence pour s'imposer aussi on
faisait des salaires qui était similaire
donc et il n'y avait pas de c'était pas
un plus gros fardeau pour un que pour
l'eau puis 5-5 puis on se dit versement
automatique dans ce conte le faisait
quand on était capable de couvrir
justement les frais mais en fait ma
question c'est plus par rapport à est-ce
que c'est toi qui prenait le lit dans
les finances que parce qu'il ya une
statistique qui est sorti l'année passée
de yoplait selon lui n'allait pas comme
cette semaine qui dit 80 2% des femmes
s'en remettent à leur conjoint ou un pot
des questions voici vos gestes que c'est
toi qui des deux c'est ta blonde et moi
tu vois pied par mois qu'on est pauvre
par l inverse - l'averse et moi j'ai dit
mettons j'ai je peux complètement oublié
par rapport aux finances mais par
rapport à mes propres finances puis mais
j'ai pas tout le temps était avec comme
elle aimait tant les relations plus
significative je pense que mamie
partenaires étaient peut-être plus
méritants
du team et ont jeté dans une relation de
travail avec mon ex et qui tous quitté
contrôler tout ce qui était facturé au
client
c'était tout elle cette quête fox était
plus celle qui était loin qui était qui
gérait flamand l'argent en général mais
c'est quand même étonnant c'est quand
même 90 % c'est beaucoup ouais parce que
on sait tous les jeux pensent les femmes
on n'est jamais vraiment on nous a
jamais vraiment parlé d' engendre la
façon que les antennes ont eu la chance
de ce type au caire je devrais je pense
que c'est que socialement acceptable
pour les gens pour les codes parler
d'argent ouvertement
versly les femmes
fait peut-être pour ça que énormément de
femmes se disent bay le monde j'aime
c'est ça qui connaît plus que moi vu que
je pense qu'il ya plus une question
sociale là dedans qui moi ça fait sept
ans que je times m puis au début et je
connaissais rien ils financent pas que
c'est lui qui puisqu'ils prenaient le
lit dans le sens que c'est moi je voyais
y avait des real je les connais on a
moins de 25 ans + camaïeu est tombé
assez lafarge est ce parce qu'il ya des
réalités mais ouais comme je connais tes
oui ils vont avec son argent
naturellement mais
ce n'était pas un critère si je disais
que j'étais jeune
j'étais impressionné par le fait que les
gaines way et moi tu vois ma blonde dans
les premières dès qu'un contenu parler
d'argent puisque j'ai déjà vu derrière
si la chose de plutôt longues
[Rires]
années à quatre semaines mais
c'est pour elle un gars qui dit mettons
qui gère ce genre bien si ses finances
personnelles mais ton se fait plus le
tissu associatif il a demandé par des
décennies aussi dans quels fonds tels
risques et
c'était pas mal inverse de toi lorsque
tu vas sortir des filles qui était un
petit d un puits puis qui quittent eux
qui regardaient pas trop ça mais ce qui
ce qui arrivait souvent à succès c'est
moi qui finissait par payer plus le tout
le temps parce que c'était moi
maintenant quiconque y paient les sens
l'épicerie bhl fait que j'ai quand même
fait un bon pivot à 180 degrés ou est ce
que le jeu me dit on paye chacun aux
enfants tout le temps vieillit pas de si
on va disputer toutes égales puis sur la
question l'autre question qui se pose
est que je trouvais super intéressante
parce que pour des raisons qui me sont
personnelles j'ai commencé à y réfléchir
dans les derniers mois le pire que ce
fait si tu es dans la société auquel on
vit est ce que vous êtes capable de
sortir quelqu'un que ça l'a largement
plus élevé que le tien et
culturellement
une fille une femme sort avec un des
cancers beaucoup plus élevé que le sien
c'est super accepté par tous le petit
bleu nous aidons nous arrive dans une
situation à ce que ça serait
potentiellement vraiment l'air
ok on va parler aux potentiels au
conditionnement mais où ça serait
potentiellement vraiment l' inverse que
je me suis posé la question type depuis
je pense que la réponse est dans le si
on a des achats comme un enfant
ce sera au pourcentage du salaire de
notre savoir qu'on est prêt à y investir
avec maintenant qu'on dit à qui on
s'achète on s'achète une maison et ont
depuis que le moi je capable de sortir
30 % de mon salaire pour un cash
d'amener les cas pas d'assortir 30% de
son salaire pour une cache d'armes et
sadique tre
maison serait pas capable de faire genre
je vais le prendre et c'est correct pour
moi ce sera d'accepter de participer au
égale pourcentage
moi j'ai tout le temps été avec des
films admettons s'est remis de relations
plus négative créé sensiblement le même
savoir que moi fakty l'espèce de est-ce
que ce qu'on paye égal tout où est ce
qu'ils ont payé ou pourcentage du revenu
se poser comme pau fait que c'est plus
simple mais tu y mets ton je me suis
amené à fréquenter une fille
tu sais pas d'une sérieux mais chanter
comme que dans la dynamique elles
s'attendaient maintenant si on va au
resto ça sera plus moi qui paie ici on
se disant force et sa plus mais qui paye
puisque la santé plus
plus dépendantes et plus justement à
s'en remettre à l'autre puis elle avait
pas vraiment de
2d peut-être moins de revenus ou moins
d'argent disponible dans les romans de
qui
ça peut durer longtemps mais j'ai pas
aimé le film en se meut ça m'est arrivé
aussi prenez ceci j'ai pas envie
d'intenses nos relations de
dead le thé avec quelqu'un comme 2 ou de
deux des provinces le tipi laissant dire
ben ayed même juste de pop nécessaires
afin de pas assumer ou ne pas assumer à
la capacité mois de temps ça va
quitter après ce je pense que dans des
bus début de relation
puis tim et ont ôté mecs on en parle
beaucoup il écrit un livre là-dessus
puis je l'entends entendu une sous en
entrevue
si je pense que dans les débuts de
relation c'est important que ça soit
plutôt égal team et on thursday tweeted
puis jusqu'à temps que ça devient
sérieux du club des vrais projets à part
ce que vous faites 50 50 pour les foules
state normalement bonfol tech bâtit sa
des patins ça fait chier parce que
on à dieu des débats super casse par
rapport à ceux ci c'était juste deux
mois ce serait tout le temps 50 % mais
l'autre fois c'était pas une force
d'appoint c'est juste genre une soirée
avec des amis le c'était juste des
coupes qui était le
puits la serveuse vienne puis là on est
toutes les gares a droit à toutes les
fées à gauche pleut tout les goûts
toutes mes amies de boris ils disent
tout mois une facture avec elle une
facture avec une facture avec une
facture à quai la mémoire ce fromage
fait deux factures avec
je me sentais comme un pur minable comme
on l'a fait hoya qui fait que quand le
meilleur mais pour moi c'est comme
battait pourquoi je vois pas pourquoi le
tennis et sur une relation qui de
beaucoup moins longue que celle de
toutes ces couleurs qui sont mariés qui
ont des enfants étaient des maisons
petit mais j'te kmt et je dire on
travaille autant
j'ai pas plus logique que doit l'état
fixe de moi ce serait tout le temps
explique
honnêtement
je trouve ça plus à votre personne et
bad mais je trouve quand même cool ici
la fille prend ligne pour briser de
suite le queen st parce que c'est sûr
qu'ils voient reconnaître quand le quand
la serveuse ou le serveur bien tous les
deux et il se dit ça parce que c'est toi
qui va le parti qui deviennent si toi tu
dis deux factures c'est ok la rosace
mais moi c'est comme l'a fait ça serait
vraiment très très très dense l indice
de facteurs
maintenant cela fait dix suspects comme
des points en plus en tabarnak parce que
c'est le hot comme qui vont arriver le
toute façon ça me prouve que toi c'est
l'adq homme que tu veux aussi puis ça
brise la connaissent dès que le savoir a
résulté et bref conseil je peux pour les
filles sortent à 15
après ce type aura des situations qui
est aimé ton c'est vraiment toi tu les
mets ton pour une occasion x mais tu
sais si c'est comme mes soucis des fois
c'est l'argument il m'a invité et
métiers je vous avais dit avant de
finalement et 2 ça vous tente de vous
voir betty les deux vélos temps est le
plus que l'autre cas moi le débat vieux
comme le monde
actif depuis red bull après celui ci les
arguments qui oui mais c'est logique
mais remettons les femmes sont plus
désavantagés financièrement donc ça
serait assez féministe que l'homme paye
la facture ou éleveurs peut-être métier
après ce jeudi il ya pas une situation
où est ce que moi je peux tenter avec
une fille qui fait deux fois moi ce que
je gagne petit et presque toutes ses
peurs ses pieds
bouchet moi je défendrai que chacun fait
son truc puis après ce tu mets ton où
nous mettons
chacun son tour et attend une fois c'est
tout une fois c'est moi aussi gros que
je sois je suis quand même dit prêt à
discuter parce que si la promettant la
première fois tu te prends plein la
deuxième fois le tchèque arrive pile eux
la thaïlande sak lé bon
il le fait à chaque fois ce qu'ils
peuvent
quitter après ce c'est une fois qu'il a
une relation est sérieuse le taux des
discussions par rapport à ce qu'ils
discutent de commande qu'on fonctionne
justement dépendamment des salaires
dépendamment de son nez des enfants qui
y en a un des deux qui décident des plus
un mètre de moins de 10 kg décident de
plus travailler ben le thé est ce normal
40 qui décident de travailler plus
contribuer plus vers toutes les
personnes qui plus en maison puis à
présent une sorte de tour des
définitions plus d'un mois souvent c'est
juste que le problème c'est que celui
qui gagne plus va imposer son mode de
vie à celui qui gagne le moins mais ce
week-end au moins doit testament puis se
sert comme dans le besoin de suivre
celui qui gagne plus mais pour ce que je
pense que le pourcentage est toujours
une bonne chose qui m'a tant que la
personne qui gagne plus fréquent mais on
s'en va en voyage à hawaï c'est comme
qui est comme était prêt à mettre ton
voyage moi je vais mettre l'équivalent
en pourcentage c'est la place de dire on
paye chacun qui a mille piastres me
manquait des pièces mbow vraiment pas la
même chose que toi avec ses dires le
voyage opté 8 mai elle même et on a
chacun notre pourcentage pour arriver à
lui mais je pense que ceci ça me sonne
comme la meilleure façon comme ça tout
le monde se met au dogme tout le monde
s'implique au même niveau dans le projet
oui sauf que c'est encore une fois ci
mais ça fait six mois avec la personne
les personnes contribuent une délégation
contribuer devrait avoir plus que
l'autre parce qu'il fait vraiment plus
pis mais que c'est peu c'est pas aussi
sérieux que finalement ça se termine
pour longtemps après ben si tu as fait
vivre une personne pendant une heure
finalement ces personnes ne paraît qu'un
autre parce que si ce n'est pas une
affaire de long terme ou des joueurs il
sait yorick choses qui marchent pas le
plus aisé moi mais moi sur ce club
existait dans toutes les situations le
nord je comprends je pense que tu es je
pense que de le respecter en double il
ya disputé
plus souvent qu'autrement égales vers
les débuts puis plus que 1 clairement
que la ration c'est
clair que c'est pour du long terme qui
est des projets communs et des
désengagements comme ayez une maison des
enfants mais le sait le triple saut mais
justement j'entendais un podcast soins
de
la personne à qui a parlé d essayer moi
mon team permet en plus pour moi qui
devrais payer pour ceux qui comme moi
mettons ma business à la peau si on fait
pas encore d'argent pendant un an puis
piliers comme kim et tim et ont pendant
combien de temps mettons tout chaud
pendant comme étant qui se financent ton
grave puisque tout de suite on rêve
mettons de partir de nice de faire des
photos projets que tu veux qu'ils
marchent tv si ton temps bénévolement
là-dedans ton chum ou tablons valable
dépendamment des situations fine jobs
qui fait un bon salaire mais c'est lui
c'est peut-être pas c'était peut-être
pas sa job de rêve mais c'est sa job qui
décide et ben mau fond rouge dans ma vie
de ce lac les autres personnes l'autre
se trouve à financer toi ton projet ton
rêve que leur cul tu que tu pousses puis
finalement qui peut-être qu'il lèvera
jamais plus finalement tu tues tu viens
un peu aux crochets de l'autre puis on
sait même pas si au final c'est de finir
je trouve l'argument bon c'est vrai
effectivement ou est ce conduit si on
veut en savoir plus ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait c'est le temps de charlotte witness
qui se construit j'allais dire toutes
les plateformes mais c'est une question
alors moi j'allais dire je suis arrivé
avec des notes je me demandais s'il y
avait des points des juridictions des
stats sous les choses que tous les
combats avant que quand on vous en a
quand même fait le taux est ce que php
quand même une petite idée comment
commencer oui
mais pour les gens mais
voilà les choses que je retiens mettons
leur tôt pour jouer au jeu ce n'était
seulement aime les choses que je retiens
le premier point que je trouve vraiment
intéressant parce que l'on dit tantôt
c'est le pays tout en premier
fake de parce que moi c'est comme ça que
fonctionne je vois de l'argent manquant
g t d'argent à mon encontre
je peux aller manger un resto sans que
ça me met là le couteau à la gorge mais
si tu perds en premier topo star j'en
attends donc on ne dépense pas en
fonction d'argenton confection c'est ce
que je vois qui la première foire la
plus intéressante de ce qu'on a dit
aujourd'hui on est plein à fait
intéressant de faire un top3 le 2 c'est
que l'investissement s'est pas besoin
d'être compliqué tu peux investir des
fonds qui sont assez simple c'est pas
toi qui as besoin d'aller vont la bourse
la matrice douleur me dois d'y aller
mais ton argent dans le fixe se met donc
de pépites chaque ou de space avant dans
un fonds qui redistribuant les shows
dans lesquels tu peux croire maintenant
un fonds ouvert ouais moi c'est ce ce
site ceci étant
ça peut être simple puis comme troisième
oui comme troisième à farges à prendre
l'idée de
demander de la pression immobilière en
disant que je peux rester locataire puis
que je pourrais mettre un montant x que
j'investirai là mon hypothèque mais qui
appela jusqu'à investir dans ses fonds
ce seraient les trois choses que je
retiendrai mettons qui en déconstruisant
bien faisant jeu simplifié vraiment tout
ce qu'on a dit à ces trois affaires le
ca me crie beaucoup moins d'anxiété et
puis je pense que je pense qu'ils aient
déjà qu'ils nous écoutent qui vont
pouvoir se reconnaître beaucoup dans ce
que pense que je vais me tourner puis il
y eu de succès mais ton de montant
minimal dans ce sens que si j'ai juste
500 pièces aux mille pièces de côté
s'ils vont au conseil financier vous
offrir votre maison d'en face où il n'ya
pas de trop petits montants pour
commencer mais ça n'est pas ça arrive
mais il est avec
comme capitale et chez le docteur
c'est peut-être qu'un mérite et le
gagner je serai
sans doute
voilà peut-être en souffrance lebel fait
appel sont deux pics
une soie prune autrefois
de penser à la réponse le mans fait
sentir partout même de pas vraiment
montant minimal séries font que je
parlais tantôt ya pas une fonction et là
partir d'ax danemark à partir d' accéder
et puis d'enfance sastre et par unité
effective site e il ya des fonds qui tu
es là comme 30 $ présentement la des
fonds qui y su s p500 fatigue tout juste
rendre là bas tu peux acheter unités
normalement dans l'achat puisque seul
évidemment ceux investis chez pas mal
dans la baie ça va être divisé par 30
sur le nombre d'unités
fait ça c'est sûr mais ce appartement
mais aussi les robes aux conseillers que
tu peux je pense déjà en berne hewson
aucun oeuf fait presque tous les
instants là
offre des robots conseiller
people4 finances mais c'est ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de professionnels dans demain à
6 comme par exemple total et ventabren
de desjardins je pense pas il ya comme
une barrière tu peux avoir 500 d'europe
y aller voir ces personnes n'étaient ils
vont ils vont te donner des conseils un
succès face à leur compte et c'est pour
des investissements amdi peu plus mais
ton substantielle j'imagine oui mais je
connais pas les montants exactement
faction
comme un planificateur financier ne veut
pas voir ces personnes là normalement
quand tu es juste 500 morts
accessible parce qu'une distinction les
syndicats des finances il ya le danton
institutions financières via l'ex france
alors quand ou si non il va le voir les
plus plats simples ouais mais en fait la
télé gens qui sont
tes insécure sage pour ça qu'on voit là
parce que cette réserve est le fait que
je sais pas quel point est-ce que la
madame après qu'elle l'ait maintenant
maman 6 et on passe être là et puis
c'est quoi
les outils qu'utilisent les des
applications utilisent maintenant
mettant justement pour des actions ou
pour faire tomber
les outils que le monde peuvent utiliser
qui facilite le le truc mon budget je le
fais à mitaine
j'ai parlé ou un excellent mais le
budget 50 points c'est quand même ça ça
donne une bonne
un vent de fraîcheur si on veut 50% pour
des besoins dans le vieux tonton dans
tout ce qui est essentielle 30% pour le
plaisir et puis 20% pour des besoins
financiers
moi c'est ce pourcentage je prend 1 20%
mettez évidemment je comprends que quand
tu fais un plus petit ça rabaisse pas
toujours tout ajusté proportions que les
besoins soient plus grands comme ce sens
par exemple plus un plus petit salaire
mais c'est juste pour donner une idée
aux gens de parce qu'il ya des gens qui
ont aucune idée ce serait le pourcentage
mais déjà savoir ce qu homme comme comme
règle comme garde là ça donne quand même
ça aide à savoir qui je suis vraiment
complètement dans le champ où ça fait du
sens exact fait qu est-ce que les gens
suivent puisque c'est le pen chaleur
tout est plate forme d'un site web tout
instinct g elle investit en un seul mot
parfait
excellent merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps c'est super cool oui
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante en option vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois sans
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
morlaàs par mois et vous avez les pas de
carte en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis art brut
et les podcasts puisse avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance car vous à l'étude de
la dynamique entre les amys tout le
temps avons une avance sur les jobs en
avance ou des centres de toi mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que le
chèque le podcast unis voulu nous en
dire davantage on fait des encore moins
de filtres à préchac podcast avec là on
vient de finir de tourner le podcast on
vend josé on va t'il et nicole non
nicolas hulot maintenant évident comme
un fils travaille la place travot détail
est là mais on jason par la conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous ses excuses et
surpiqûres il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous